presidente francisco sagasti juramento a
óscar ugarte como nuevo ministro de
salud a él le tocará desempeñar el cargo
en el momento más difícil de la pandemia
del coi 19 que vive este país con altos
índices de contagios y decesos
oscar ugarte además de dirigir la
vacunación tendrá que solucionar los
reclamos de los médicos que exigen
mejoras salariales y laborales
ugarte se integra al gobierno de
francisco sagasti tras la renuncia de
pilar mazzetti quien dimitió tras el
escándalo que relaciona al ex presidente
de martín vizcarra con las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 destino farc luego
que un medio local denunciara que martín
vizcarra y su esposa habrían sido
inoculados en octubre pasado esto
disgustó a varios congresistas quienes
responsabilizan a masetti y promovieron
una moción de la institución desde el
parlamento contra ella masetti se sintió
acorralada por el legislativo y dimitió
francisco sagasti decidió entonces
llamar a un conocido en gestión pública
para atender la pandemia así las cosas
esta noche oscar ugarte recibirá
setecientas mil dosis de la vacuna china
y scinopharm para continuar la primera
fase de vacunación de los
peruanos